what makes me laugh funny stuff fart
jokes make me laugh people other people
be like laughing at other people's
despair people laugh at me and people
laugh with him definitely mad do you
think you're funnier than me I never
thought about it let's not like drive
this wedge between us right now like
we're both funny period you're so
serious sob oh my dog oh wow
knock knock who's there
Amos Amos who a mosquito hey you and you
like try to fight a fart no that's it
papa poppy night baby eat peanut pudding
pudding put put it
pudding pudding up
dance like that when we exercise
together God you look okay I love it
it's so cute I think I played into your
weaknesses knowing how you'd react
I'd say the hardest part is not making
any sound I feel like my strength and
comedy is like words and word play
usually we laugh like immediately or
even before we start telling you to I
mean I was basically just laughing to
make him feel better so I don't think
that's fair the hardest part was being
unprepared I feel like I can be a funny
person but it's really hard to be funny
without any kind of like someone
stimulus try hards they have had in a
while